[Music]
hey
happy sunday everybody yep look we uh
put the party lights on back there we're
we're playing with danger yeah real
slow put them on the slowest possible
setting maybe that might uh maybe that
might
be easier for the cpu to process i don't
know as long as we stay really really
still
we'll just stare at you there's not much
movement there's a whole bunch of
movement
i think it just sucks up a bunch of data
i know now i'm like really nervous about
moving it or anything like that like
waving my
hearts around i don't know we're gonna
find out we're gonna find out if that's
what it was
yeah it may have been what it was that
would it would solve a lot of problems
wouldn't it
yeah i mean it kind of would kind of
suck like not having it on during the
party streams and stuff
just because it's but you know maybe if
it's slow i don't know
yeah i know we're living on the edge
yeah he says if you [ __ ] look at
those lights too long you're gonna get
asleep i probably will it's like
yeah i'm looking at him on my little
monitor and i'm just sitting there going
oh i'm getting like all hypnotized
it hits the eyes you guys just make us
look more pretty
[Laughter]
we're the most beautiful people in the
whole world
yeah see t says she's gonna watch
justice league and red son
holy crap yeah after she gets off this
that's gonna that's gonna be a
yeah quite a redstone's not long though
yeah it's not i think it's only
what 80 something minutes or something
but yeah i really liked it it's got a
good
fast pace i like i like the animated
stuff
i think a lot of superhero stuff
translates better to animation
because it's yeah it's not real you know
[Laughter]
i only i only want people to make movies
about real things yeah
no you got to pass it off as reality
it's just
my favorite superhero movie that's live
action in recent years is actually
shazam
yeah because shazam is was [ __ ] goofy
that's fun i want a sequel yeah i want a
sequel to
well it seemed like it was pretty
successful so i'm sure they'll get
around to doing it
doing a sequel one of these for me
that's that that's a superhero movie
well yeah like i said yeah because it
was just fun and then like i said that
guy that was in it you know
being like a little kid in a yeah adult
superhero's body that's pretty much
exactly how that [ __ ] would go
um so i have a very special shout out i
want to do today
it's i feel really bad because she
messaged me on
patreon um and she wanted to shout out
for the friday night show but i didn't
see it in time
and we didn't do it yesterday you know
we didn't do a stream yesterday
so happy belated birthday it was their
late it was their birthday yesterday
to shane nicole and her twin sister
stacy okay
it's like they're they'd be very excited
i don't know if they're here or not but
um i told i told her that i would like
shout them out on sunday because i felt
really bad because i didn't see her
message until after we'd already
streamed on friday
so i was like so now we're shouting out
so happy belated birthday you guys it
was their birthday yesterday
uh so you know now i don't feel so bad
[Laughter]
so we are going to be talking about this
new netflix documentary that they put up
i guess they just put it up yesterday
because
i you know i only just saw it come up
and it's called the last blockbuster
what are you doing something's not right
with our lighting there you go
there you go oh pookie's over here
[ __ ] with it
she's just over here just knocking [ __ ]
off all the time
but yeah so uh we saw this had come up
last night and i was like oh that sounds
fun so
uh we'll watch that so we watched it
last night before that i was actually
gonna do
they had added this new movie on shutter
remember that swedish movie that we
watched
um and i was like oh well yeah and i was
just kind of like well we can talk about
that one of it but then i was just kind
of i didn't hate it
but that movie had serious problems it
was uh
it was pretty slow and and i don't
usually mind that it's like the
the movie it's called cocode cocoda yeah
and um
don't bother with that [ __ ] yeah it was
it was only like 85 minutes long but it
felt like
it went on for like a year it was a
movie
it was a movie written around
totally unlikable characters there's not
a single character in there that was
worth the [ __ ]
if you ask me except the one
one the one of the monsters was a girl
she had cool hair
i like that yeah i totally was like oh i
want to do that for a halloween costume
took some out of the band rap tina yeah
she looked like a raspberry
chick that was really the only good part
of the movie the rest of it man i was
like why'd they but why'd they make this
the the hero of the movie was the
biggest coward in the [ __ ] world
wouldn't go out and save his girlfriend
he tried but man
everyone it was like he was caught in
like a time loop yeah it was like a like
a purgatory
situation he could he could try over and
over again to save her
and not a single time did he try to
a frontal assault and just go and attack
him he never tried that well in the
first few times he was just like man
[ __ ] her i'm out of here
yeah and i was like i was like that's
nice and they did
they did like make sure to show him
without his shirt that he was
he was a weakling you know he had a
little he was just there just nothing to
him he was
maybe 130 pounds but the thing is is
that you're
in a situation like that you want to
root for the underdog
you you want the maybe the little guy to
win and who he was fighting
only one of them was big i mean it just
it was it was stupid
i think it there was some kind of a
moral or some kind of yeah there was it
was like a symbolic sort of story like i
said a purgatorial type situation and it
was some kind of moral and it had some
kind of like folkloric thing to it i
like that but it's like
it just it went on like way too long and
it just was like real repetitive
whatever moral it was teaching it was a
bad one it did
it just was well i don't think like i
said i think it more had to do with like
the death of their daughter and them
like reliving [ __ ] like over and over
again
like because they couldn't get out of
this yeah that was like grief whatever
clear though
well i mean that's what i got out of it
that's what it seemed like with all the
animations when you're making a film and
telling a story you have to make certain
things clear
so there's so at least you understand
what it is you're being shown and
what's the what the meaning of the movie
is and what you're supposed to take from
it it's part of storytelling
and this really that well thank you for
explaining about that yeah yeah
it's pretty obvious it's a shame that
you have
that i have to say that but there's a
lot of these movies today some of them
come from big studios they don't know
how telling stories
well like i said that's why i didn't
really want to do that yeah movie today
even though we just ended up yeah
anyway but um but yeah so we ended up
watching this
uh this new documentary that they put on
netflix last night uh called the last
blockbuster and this one's actually
pretty charming it's not
it's not real like um in depth or
anything but if you liked um
netflix's stuff like you know the toys
that made us the movies that made us
stuff like it's kind of in the same
along that same vein so this is about i
don't know if you guys know but there is
actually one sad
remaining blockbuster video store in
bend oregon
and so this documentary is probably like
half about that store or maybe like
three quarters about that store
and then the other part is kind of just
about blockbuster in general like they
have a bunch of you know comedians and
stuff like that like
talking about their memories of
blockbuster some of them used to work
there and they kind of talked about that
and they kind of talked a little bit
they went a little bit into the history
of like what
ended up happening with blockbuster
which
you know i mean the simple answer being
well netflix killed it which
in a way it did because [ __ ] was going
towards streaming and they just weren't
quick enough to jump on that bandwagon
but the thing is they probably would
have gone out of business anyway
because i think they got bought out by
i think it was viacom yeah like the
company that owned mtv and paramount
pictures and all that kind of [ __ ]
and they and they actually i can't
remember exactly what happened but they
ended up buying
blockbuster and they took on so
blockbuster ended up like taking on all
of this debt
so even though they were still making
money like i think i think at their
height which was 2004 which is crazy
because i thought it was longer ago than
that
but um you know they had like 9 000
stores and they were like doing really
successfully but because
you know the corporate overlords had
taken them on and taken on so much debt
even had they you know even had they got
on the
streaming bandwagon or the mail order
bandwagon
as it was back then they probably
wouldn't have succeeded and there's
there was much made too of the fact that
they were offered
netflix when netflix was still pretty
dinky and they said no
because i i mean i'm old enough to
remember and you're probably
you're old enough to remember too that i
can remember when dirt was invented
well yeah so i remember when dinosaurs
roamed the earth
but um so the thing about netflix was
when it first
came out it was a mail order service
obviously you got a movie in the mail
and you watched it and you wouldn't get
your next movie on your list you made a
list on their website
and then they would send you the new
movie when you sent back the old one and
you could
you know if you paid more per month you
could have more still got some of their
movies yeah you probably did
they never charge me anything for them
yeah well they don't yeah i don't do
that anymore i don't even know if they
do
i think they discontinued that fairly
recently but um
unless somebody knows that if you still
if they still send you dvds
i got a tomb raider here yeah that's
right you do don't you yeah still got it
but um
let's say we had a huge list and every
time i send one back they'd send me one
well yeah that's not like that's how i
don't want one stop sending to him but i
i yeah i lost the ability to
any [ __ ] them why does it matter now no
it doesn't matter
yeah but um yeah because like i said i
don't know if they still do that
if they do it's a very very tiny portion
of their [ __ ] uh
if their market share but um so they
were like
pretty small and then when they first
came out with the whole mail order thing
i think blockbuster and pretty much
every other like movie studios and
everybody that's man that's not gonna
work
because people are just gonna keep the
movies and you're just going to lose
your shirt
well uh you know here we are
yeah most people did send it back just
fine it worked out just fine
yeah and then well they were still
thinking they were still in the mindset
okay well this is something that that
the documentary does cover
it goes way back to the early 80s
when we were kids when they had us
fooled into thinking that a vhs tape was
worth a hundred dollars
and that went on even in the late 80s
and early 90s because i
specifically remember when rocky horror
picture show
first came out on vhs and i don't even
remember when that was maybe it was 89
something like that i want to say yeah
and i went to media play because i
wanted to buy it and it was 98.99 and i
was like
[ __ ] that yeah the people that were that
owned studios that made these
dvd or dvds and vhs tapes
they thought in terms of theater seats
and theater sales
because they wanted to think that way
because that's that's where all the
profit was
they didn't really think about mass
marketing or mass media
they're shysters you know a matter of
fact that one dude he actually called it
that guy who did toxic avengers he said
lloyd kaufman
yeah he said if you work in the industry
you're scum of the earth
as you said you're the scum scum of the
earth he wasn't a big fan of blockbuster
either yeah
they had him out there for a few minutes
and being cranky about that yeah
you work in hollywood you're [ __ ]
scum okay and what they would do is
is they would say well wait a minute
hold on if you rent this via
if i sell you this vhs tape how many of
your family members are gonna watch it
because that's like eight nine people so
you owe us a hundred dollars
yeah that was kind of what they're
thinking that was there thank you and
they went into that in this documentary
too
they were too narrow-minded to realize
that no if you sell it [ __ ] for [ __ ]
499
599 or 10 everybody in the damn
everybody will buy one everybody will
buy one of those vhs tapes
yeah more people will buy it than rent
it and more people will
buy those vhs tapes then go to your
[ __ ] movies in the damn theaters
they didn't think that way though why
because
their cousin also owned the theater
chains so they were trying to make
like a monopoly between people that were
you know loosely affiliated or sometimes
actually related
um they were they were trying to make a
monopoly without making it look like a
monopoly but they couldn't hold it
together
the interesting thing too oh my goodness
what are you doing about that
she said she's like play attention to me
leave
yeah but uh one thing that they got that
they went into a little bit in the
documentary and actually i did not know
this
but when um you know when it started
becoming a thing
like vhs rental and remember we used to
have to rent vcrs too because they were
really expensive yeah i really like to
watch the movies you needed a credit
card to do it yeah and only rich people
had credit cards that was
my thinking at the time well yeah not
everybody had credit cards
yeah well i remember when credit cards
were new
yeah yeah yeah i remember i mean they've
had them like going back to
before we were born but a lot of they
weren't like real widespread
the first real widespread credit card i
remember was something called diners
club
yeah and i think it was only in certain
restaurants
yeah yeah isn't that weird it had
american express but you had to pay all
that [ __ ] at the end of the month
yeah that was it was another time yeah
weird
so uh but yeah but something i didn't
know was that when
uh vhs first started to be a thing um
the movie studios tried to because
so what would happen like the movie
studios were like okay we'll put our
movies out on
vhs but they'll be like a hundred
dollars each at which point
some kind of enterprising people who
opened up some of the first video stores
were like hey if we buy a copy and we
rent this
out to people for two three bucks um
then we'll make our money back like
really really quickly so
a few businesses started doing that like
back in the early 80s
and the movie studios that owned the
rights to the movies tried to sue them
because they're like hey you can't do
that like even though legally you bought
a copy
and now you're renting it out to other
people for money that's not cool and i
think it went all the way to the supreme
court but the supreme court said nah bro
it's like if that was the case
then libraries couldn't buy books and
you know loan them out to people for
free
it's like it's the same kind of thing
they bought the movie
they can do whatever the [ __ ] they want
with it it's their property now
so you know you you have the right to
like rent it out so so after that
supreme court decision i guess that's
kind of when the whole video sort of
thing exploded
but yeah so the interesting thing is
that when this documentary
i guess they first started working on it
in 2017
and at that point i think there were
still
four blockbusters left there was the one
in bend oregon which as far as i know is
still there
um and then there were three of them in
alaska of all places like the other
three were in alaska there was like
there was one in anchorage which was
still doing okay
but while they were working on the
documentary the three in alaska like
ended up closing now the one in bend
oregon
it's really interesting because they you
know there's really not
any corporate support anymore so like
what the lady that manages it
um that they you know she's kind of like
a main character in the documentary
and she's like well sometimes we'll get
a shipment from the studio of x amount
of new movies or whatever and put those
she's like but
in a lot of cases like lesser known
stuff and indie stuff or you know stuff
people ask for that we don't have
she has to go to [ __ ] target or
walmart and buy the [ __ ] herself
for the store and then rent it out which
is so they showed her like being in
target and like looking at all the
movies and like trying to find a [ __ ]
cheap and stuff
but a lot of people that live in bend
oregon are kind of like well
you know even though it's still like a
corporate chain not really anymore
because there's just one of them
um you know this woman and her whole
entire family
like have worked there for she's worked
there for like 14 years all her kids
worked there like a bunch of her family
members worked there
a bunch of other teenagers in the town
worked there when they were growing up
so it's like everybody knows her and
everybody knows you know so when
they have people come in and rent movies
she's like oh yeah they they're like all
you have to do is ask for a movie if
they don't have and she will go out and
buy it and like let you rent it and [ __ ]
like that so it's like really cool and
also they have
um i guess a few years ago when they
became the last state the last one
standing
there was so much media attention about
it
that now people make like pilgrimages to
it
like to take pictures because i think
even dan bell like drove up there like
he did a channel about it's like a
little i want to smell it
that you could only get in a in a
blockbuster
that had a certain smell when you walked
in and it was kind of like popcorn
and plastic yeah they didn't burnt
plastic
kind of smell too which i can kind of
remember how they smell yeah i remember
that um
the movie it's a good movie it's on
netflix and uh it's worth watching it's
kind of like watching one of dan bell's
dead mall videos
which that was the right way that they
edited it and everything it's kind of
like a walk down memory lane
they have a lot of interviews with
people that grew up they're old
now you know what i mean but grew up in
the 90s in the in you know
going to [ __ ] blockbuster there was
also there were some other video rental
chains that we used to go to you know
like [ __ ] what was the black and red one
west coast or something central west
coast
well there was one called suncoast but
that wasn't a rental place
that was you that was you bought stuff
that was movie memorabilia that there
was like a mall store blockbuster
had like a montpar competitor that
usually was in a strip mall
usually liquor stores there were some oh
my god
they actually had x-rated [ __ ] in there
yeah that was kind of the one thing
about well blockbuster
something something coast video or
something
it was the same thing as blockbuster
it's just that they weren't quite as big
um they had
porn they had a lot more horror movies
and stuff
like we were going to see some special
[ __ ] we were going to go to that one but
i forgot which one it was
and the motif was red white and black
you don't remember that one
it was in detroit or maybe we didn't
maybe we didn't have it here
it's in michigan we had
we had one i think it was a chain the
one that we grew up going to before we
even had because i grew up in daytona
beach we didn't have a blockbuster until
probably like
the 90 like mid 90s i want to say like
early mid 90s we didn't have one until
then
uh but prior to that we had movie
gallery my boy was
my boy was in the in there he would
remember because he he
hollywood videos might have been yeah
like i said there is suncoast but that
was in the mall and that wasn't a rental
place that was
you bought movies what in the hell
what the [ __ ] look at her she stopped
turning look at it she's
she moved like this she pushed the
monitor out of the way
now clothes are in there clothes are in
there i'm gonna close you in here pookie
yeah oh she does not like it when uh
when we're doing it yeah she's like you
guys are not paying attention these
[ __ ] humans are always talking to
these lights
not petting me she's like tearing up my
[ __ ]
oh now she's like pulling my little
towel like under there i can see your
little eyeballs like
grandpa scrampers would remember what
video it was but yeah we had that
because that was one of the things about
blockbuster
was that one no porn uh you know that
which wasn't a deal breaker obviously
but they also didn't have anything
real i mean that was the place you went
if you wanted like a new release
but if you wanted oh my god but if you
wanted like some
obscure [ __ ] or some old [ __ ] or you
wanted something that was unrated
you know what i mean like a horror movie
that was unrated that was uncut
then you couldn't go there and get it
because they i don't even think they
would carry stuff that was nc 17
or they would only carry like a censored
version i looked at hollywood video it
wasn't hollywood video
yeah that's way too upscale in the um
was there one called show time or show
something i remember
it was like i remember black
and then it had um the motif was like
the side of a damn
film can real you know it's like a
circle with
a round thing with circles in it like
like the side of a film can yeah
i think that's what it was and it might
have had kind of like
in in the advertisement around globe
with
lines going through it but it didn't
really have a world it just you know i
mean it had like a globe it almost
looked like basketball if you ask me
[Laughter]
i think that was in there
i almost want to say showtime or showbiz
or something like that although showbiz
that's the pizza place and
like the competition let me look and see
even though showtime isn't that's a
that's a that's a cable
cable channel yeah which is still around
but yeah it's just
so this like one little blockbuster
they have it's so funny because i guess
there was a whole thing and i kind of
remember when this happened but
when there was still four of them open
like on john oliver's show
he was kind of they his show bought all
of this russell crowe memorabilia
like including the jock strap that he
wore in
uh gladiator or whatever the [ __ ] maybe
it was
and um he donated it to the anchorage
store so then when the anchorage store
ended up closing
the only remaining blockbuster in bend
oregon
got all of the russia brussel chrome
members except for the
jock strap i don't know what happened to
the jock strap that's they just left me
hanging on that i don't know why they
like they got his robe and everything
from cinderella man and whatnot but it's
like so they um
yeah so so the pet show paid for them to
have like the display cases and
everything
and another thing they're doing too like
the manager she's pretty smart because
because it's the last one and she did
all these
this big like media blitz about it and
now you have people coming from like
miles around
uh to come to the last one so she
started selling
um you know members like she makes
little
blue and yellow beanies like to sell in
the store they make t-shirts
uh so they have all this kind of stuff
and they have all this memorabilia that
people have donated um you know their
old cards and stuff
so i don't know it's a you know the
at the end of the documentary they were
kind of like well
every year they have to like renew their
um you know their corporate whatever you
call it the contract or whatever
and she's like and we you know every
year we're scared that they're going to
say okay
we we're not going to renew it anymore
because you're like the last one
but it might have been movie time movie
time
i think it might have been movie time
yeah okay maybe we had one
of those i don't really remember like i
said when i was younger
we started out going to movie gallery
which had which was kind of
uh you know kind of janky yeah um i
think it's a chain
but it might have been movie time but it
was real
kind of scuzzy yeah they were kind of
but they had um
but they had a lot of horror movies and
they had some corn they had some porn in
the back
that's what we've got with the saloon
doors yeah which i laughed because
somebody on the documentary said
something about the porn
room with the saloon doors i'm like oh
my god that's what movie gallery the
only picture i could find at movie time
it looked like they kind of updated the
sign
yeah at the time that i'd last saw it
like maybe i saw the old motif
i think it might have been a movie time
that sounds kind of familiar
but no he went there for more hardcore
horror flicks
yeah because some [ __ ] they wouldn't
have it blockbuster
you know what i mean yeah like i said
they were real focused on having 40
bajillion
well and having 40 bajillion copies of
new releases that was always their thing
so you could always get it
yeah and we'd also creep down there
[ __ ] when your buddies weren't with
you you get to pour
yeah yeah and then you talk about the
porn afterwards like you didn't do it
man i said you read that one no it was
something rather than you know new way
poker
17 did you see that one oh yeah yeah
yeah i saw that one
yeah that's [ __ ] funny i mean most of
the it's
you gotta say like most of the form but
from back then was just it was terrible
it was just like so [ __ ] what's funny
is it's like it was shot with like a
handheld
store-bought video cam recorder either
that yeah or
you could tell they had to set up a
bunch of lights
in somebody's bedroom or in a hotel room
to [ __ ]
shoot the scene and it's really only got
like three or four angles to the whole
[ __ ] scene
and they and maybe it was 10 minutes
worth of material that they edited to
get edited together
and patted it out to try to get 20
minutes
yeah it was [ __ ] that [ __ ] was cheap
it was it was
but then like you kind of had like some
of the beginnings of like homemade porn
and [ __ ]
coming where you know people were able
to afford their own cameras
think it was like oh shane's world and
stuff it's kind of like reality porn
yeah it got better when that happened
well and the thing about it well yeah
the thing about it now is that porn is
really
there's not a stigma about it anymore
and the technology is so much cheaper
yeah anybody can do it that anybody can
do it and it looks good it's like back
then
people were like people were kind of you
know you weren't really supposed to do
it so people were kind of like
when you shifty hotels
mistakes too like to have the camera you
know what i mean they're trying to
trying to shoot the scene have the
camera then they'd point it towards the
window and of course everything would
black out
like pay attention what you're doing
dude
back in our day they couldn't even they
couldn't even film porn properly
it's [ __ ] hilarious but yeah so i
um yeah i knew the the story you were
talking about i knew it wasn't movie
gallery because i'm pretty sure that the
movie gallery logo
was the letters were yellow and then i
think the background was like
black and white it was like a it was
like a black and white like marquee
and then i think it said movie gallery
and yellow letters if i'm remembering
correctly
but yeah that was the one we started
going to and then blockbuster came along
in the i want to say it was the mid 90s
because i think it opened up in a strip
mall
that was right across the street from
the apartment where i
used to live but i had moved from that
apartment like two or three years prior
and i think i moved out of that
apartment in 1991
so because i remember i had to drive
then to get to the blockbuster let me
ask you if there's one called movie
gallery yeah that's the one that i used
to go to
i think the one in michigan was called
movie time it's movie i think it's
called movie time
and like i said it was always in a like
a second or third rate strip mall
yeah next to a liquor store yeah right
next to a liquor store or
like one of those like really janky nail
salons
mattresses yeah yeah what is it with
did we like watch something about that
because i feel like there's a lot of
places in strip malls that sell
mattresses and you never see anybody in
there
and i'm always just kind of like how
often do people buy mattresses how how
does a city like sustain
that many mattress places i mean the
markup on the ship
there was actually somebody doing an
investigative [ __ ]
see i thought we did because i'd always
wondered about that too like goddamn
there's another mattress place nobody's
ever in there and they're like
some people had all these theories that
it was like a money laundering scheme
see that's what i always thought
what it is they're like they're direct
sale companies kind of like kirby and
electrolux was for vacuum cleaners
okay all right it doesn't cost much to
make a mattress uh the technology's out
there to make it
um they're a very high profit item
and the direct sales people are in there
and um usually like one or two work
out of one it's kind of like a salesman
slash branch manager
they make you know 150 to 200 bucks per
sale
per sale on a mattress so
the salesman so if they sell one or two
a week they can keep their head above
the water
they sell three a week they made good
money they made a good i guess so
because it just seems like we went to
a lot of it has to do is that they have
a truck and did they deliver it to your
house
yeah because you can't carry it with you
you know what i mean
she's like no i'll just walk home yeah
most people can't carry it with them
i'll just put it in a bag you just have
to go somewhere you know because how
much
you know and they're trying to sell them
these high-end mattresses you know what
i mean like they're trying to sell you a
1500
1500 mattress that's what they're trying
to do which i think the last time
we went to that mattress one place next
to the chinese restaurant
didn't it and uh yeah there was like
nobody in there but it's like we bought
one
when was it was like a 300 i think it
was 300 or 400 dollars
fell apart within about three years yeah
i think we had it for three or four
years then we had a bunch yeah
oh well what are you gonna do yep um but
yeah it's just like
i always just kind of wondered about
that because there are so many of those
[ __ ] places and you never see anybody
in there
all right so um yeah so this documentary
is on
uh netflix and actually like i said it's
not a huge deep dive or anything but
it's kind of like if you liked the toys
that made us that kind of thing it's
that kind of
uh it's that kind of vibe to it it's
just kind of fun louis
and there's one called west coast video
i think there was yeah
i thought that was the one that i was
thinking of
but it doesn't make sense that that
would be in michigan
unless they were everywhere they're like
well uh maybe it's on the west coast of
the great lakes
it's a coast kind of see what they're
what it looked like
yeah that may have been it it's that red
see oh yeah okay so we didn't maybe the
old version that might have been west
coast video
we didn't have that might have been i
don't
if it was if it was in michigan
well i'm sure you could like wikipedia
that [ __ ] you could like cause it's red
it was even that or movie time one of
the two movie
would kind of look like it also yeah
it's cr it's just crazy to think that
blockbuster you know
that was like the thing that you did
especially like teenagers or college
students or whatever that was what you
did friday night saturday night that was
like your date night now it's like
netflix and chill but it's like you go
to blockbuster
you'd [ __ ] pick you'd pick out a
couple movies get some candy you'd go
next door to pizza hut and pick up a
pizza or whatever
it was a national chain so yeah oh okay
that may have been it i don't think we
had any of those i don't remember that
sign
i just mostly i just remember movie
gallery blockbuster and a couple of
just like real generic mom and pop ones
you know what i mean but um yeah that's
pretty much all i remember
so yeah gum gomer kyle gomer kyle says
we had a west coast video in tennessee
so there you go and sheila and said they
had one in pennsylvania and in tennessee
okay so
there's a good chance that it might have
been that was either that or movie time
the movie time we might have had three
or four of them so they all kind of
sound familiar with me
to me you know yeah they all kind of
have names let's close videos
it had porn it had
better we had it had more it had better
much better um horror movies
than blockbuster had yeah because it
didn't have all the [ __ ] like
cut versions uh the store itself was
smaller you know how
you know how um blockbuster would have
like those bookshelf looking things
and they'd have the uh the movie laid
out so you could see all the covers
yeah it wasn't like that it was more
like a library they were filed
yeah yeah i mean they could get more of
them in a smaller area
yeah you know and i think some of the
[ __ ]
i think some of it wasn't in in those
cases it's been a long time
i think some of it might have just been
like a library
where you had the number and you told
them what number you wanted yeah
you know now that i'm thinking about it
you could look at it but then you know
movie gallery yeah it's like what they
would do is that all the boxes on the
shelf were empty i
totally forgot about that yeah you
brought the empty box up to the thing
and then they would give you the movie
because they only had like a couple
copies of [ __ ] that's right that was why
blockbuster got so massive because they
were just like we have
all the copies of [ __ ] you know
whatever movie was rolled
like [ __ ] jurassic park you taking
the damn porn up to the front [ __ ]
counter and [ __ ] you had to put it in a
bag or something
i don't remember them doing that at
movie gallery i remember yeah they could
say
because there'd be little kids and [ __ ]
up front i mean not like i was renting
porn and movie gallery but i'm just
saying that like
of people that i knew that were renting
porn i think i think they just kind of
carried the box up there maybe they just
kind of put it under their arms
by the time the very late 80s started
rolling around
i was amazed that just like and it
seemed like it happened overnight
a vhs player went from being like a
thousand dollars
i remember when it wasn't like a hundred
dollars or 150
and a half over [ __ ] night oh it
seemed like it didn't
i mean i'm sure it took longer than that
but it didn't seem like it and then like
a couple months later
you'd have these samsung televisions
with the vhs player
yeah i had one and they were like 200
bucks they were [ __ ] everywhere
it wasn't a big tv it was only small it
was like 13 inches or 15 inches or
something yeah those things were [ __ ]
everywhere and they were good they never
did break
i had one until it went obsolete chet
man i have virtually you just left it
behind
well yeah because it was just cheaper to
buy another buy a new one
and then after dvd players came out it's
like you couldn't get rid of the [ __ ]
you could get nobody wanted your vhs
player anymore yeah it was a [ __ ] it
was a different time
yeah crazy now everybody just like now
everything's just out in the cloud
yeah you can just watch he says please
hit the like button thanks t i'm gonna
hit the like button
do you always forget to do that you
should do that every time
you should do that every time we need as
many likes as we can get love us
please but yeah so uh so yeah this was a
good documentary it was pretty fun
yeah i knew a little bit like i said i
knew a little bit about the last
blockbuster in bend oregon because
dan bell did a show about it and i guess
a lot of other youtubers have been up
there
kind of talking especially ones that
were like 90s kids because i feel like
blockbuster was kind of more of a 90s
phenomenon i guess than an 80s
phenomenon
i did go there when i was there in the
80s i
late 80s well like i said i don't think
we had one in daytona until the 90s
so we so if we wanted to rent movies we
always went to movie gallery
when i came back from brazil and went to
uh trenton michigan
[ __ ] blockbuster was like that that
was like the central [ __ ] event
for when i was still in high school that
was like the central event for the
weekend
yeah they were all gonna go we went to
the [ __ ]
arcade first and spent about 20 bucks a
piece
in [ __ ] quarters video games
and then we go get a [ __ ] movie and
then um
we'd watch movies all night yeah we go
you know we'd we'd go and like pick a
whole everybody would pick one yeah
you know what i mean you go and make
sure you have like a pile of them and
then like i said then usually you'd like
pick up a pizza or something
or you'd order a pizza when you got home
but then like we we all started dating
so that started to break down we had to
change the nights
[Laughter]
we would like date on friday but then
we would uh [ __ ] do movies and [ __ ]
on saturday
yeah yeah sometimes we date on saturday
though too
but that was just but watching movies
that was like a guy thing
really i did that too yeah no i'm
talking about you only dead with other
guys oh okay
you didn't you didn't invite girls over
they didn't want to see movies with you
i don't want to watch movies with you
yeah they don't want to no they don't
want to watch movies they either want
you they either wanted to [ __ ] go out
on a date
and that didn't tell you at all kinds of
[ __ ] you spent a bunch of money for
going to eat and then you know [ __ ]
driving around already going to the lace
area
they're lazy area going to see the pink
floyd
yeah just yeah it had all kinds of
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] getting high
i seen it at some of those laser shows
in the planetarium those are fine i saw
the pink floyd one a bunch of times i
saw the duran duran one i saw the
beatles one
greatest [ __ ] everybody somehow i ended
up it's a journey one even though i
really don't like journey i think well i
think it was just like i was with a
bunch of people and we were like we're
[ __ ] bored what are we going to do we
went to a gary newman one
oh
[Music]
not the wall it was a dark side of the
moon yeah yeah
i saw that one a couple of times it was
weird yeah
all right so you have anything else
you'd like to add nah that's it
yeah tila was saying i used to hate to
check out my movies and the person
commenting on my selections like shut up
did i ask you
now i do kind of like that um some
people
and they did kind of go into this on the
documentary too where if they said
you know you're a real good employee and
you really build trust in your customers
if they come up to rent something and if
the customer asks
you is this movie any good and you're
like nah man that sucks don't waste
[ __ ] money on it
um then they said the customers really
like appreciated that
another thing remember that they had it
west coast
video that they didn't have at
blockbuster was anime
we would go in there and get [ __ ]
anime yeah like akira
that level yeah yeah see blockbuster
didn't have sheldon you get like akira
and there was
another one was called appleseed and
then there the apple seed was a
i remember that one um there was there
was a bunch of good uh
there was a weird one it was kind of
like a
kind of like a soap opera called rhonda
one half that was a weird one there's
shampoo
weird [ __ ] um it's kinda
almost kind of like it i didn't really
get it at the time
i didn't really understand what it was
looking back on it it was kind of like
kind of like a i don't know teen romance
type
[ __ ] but it was i was like what the hell
is this why because i was used to anime
being real kind of violent
or kind of like hentai it's kind of yeah
like sexual [ __ ] but it's a massive
yeah but it's a massive show it's not
just one genre
genres just yeah there was another one
about
[ __ ] some devil um
demons set like sex demons but it wasn't
the one that we saw it was another one
it was like that
yeah it was weird well like i said that
was kind of the problem that i had with
blockbuster if i wanted to see like a
new release yeah that's where you would
go but if you wanted to see something
old or like kind of a cult thing or
you know some extreme horror or
something like that then you didn't go
there because they didn't have it
you had to go to like some mom-and-pop
plays to get that [ __ ] you know
all right so uh i guess that'll do it
for
today's matinee we'll be back tomorrow 3
p.m eastern standard time talking about
another movie i don't know what it's
going to be yet but i guess we'll find
out we'll
we'll be surprised and you'll be
surprised alright so uh thanks
everybody for dropping by remember hit
the like button if you haven't done it
already
and we will see you guys tomorrow bye